I appreciate that. I also have another
question. Um I hope this doesn't I don't
want to trigger you because I'm really
being genuine with it. All right, man. I
can get triggered the people.
But um when it comes to you like um
cursing people out or insulting people,
when it comes to you cursing people out
and insulting people or calling people,
I think it's hilarious. But uh other
people are more sensitive. So why would
you why would you explain to them like
why you do that? Yeah. Yeah. I I tell
people because I'm not your cup of tea.
I don't expect you to agree with me. You
have your own conviction and we all have
to answer to the
Lord. My approach is my approach. Now,
my prayer always is and I mean this from
my heart. If I am transgressing the
limits, the Holy Spirit reign me in,
tighten his bit in my mouth, tighten his
leash on my neck, convict me to change
for the glory of Christ, not for the
praise of men. So I say, okay, I
understand. you don't need to listen to
me because I'm not your cup of tea. I'm
not the only teacher on the planet. The
Christian faith does not revolve around
me and I'm not the center of attention.
So, some people are going to like me,
some people are going to hate me. That's
okay. There are some te teachers I like,
some teachers I dislike. For example,
there is one particular teacher I listen
to. When he comes on, I love it. I'm not
going to mention his name. But then he's
got someone else that works alongside.
When he comes, I can't stand looking at
him.
No. Uh, so what's my point? Some people
are going to be drawn to David Wood.
Some people are going to be drawn
to God logic. Some people are going to
be be drawn to Jay Apologetics and
daughter of Christ. Some people are be
going to be drawn to me. Some people
can't stand David Wood. Some people
can't stand me. This is just the nature
of things. And I'm glad it's this way
because you don't want if you truly love
the Lord and I truly do want to love the
Lord, you don't want to become the
center of attention and the focus where
everyone looks to you. That's how cults
are formed.
Yeah. So I don't want to be fake in
order to appease people. I want to be
real and genuine, but at the same time
without angering the Lord. So am I
always spoton? Am I walking the tight
rope carefully? No, because I'm a
sinner. Now, with that said, there is a
biblical basis. Now, does that mean I'm
always following the
biblical pattern? No. Because I'm a
sinner, dude. I mean, there of course
I'm pretty certain I have sinned in my
anger and unleashing on dogs. But to say
there is no basis to insult people,
ridicule people, belittle people, then
they have a different Bible from what
God has given us. If you read from
Genesis to Revelation, the Bible is the
most transparent and honest and open
book about the characters in the
narrative. It tells you their sins black
and white. It tells you their evils.
Doesn't sugarcoat it. But at the same
time, you will find examples where men
of God, women of God, and our Lord
himself are belittling people, insulting
people in the most graphic way, and it's
not a sin because that's what they
deserve. There's a time and place for
everything. Yes sir. So this why I tell
people if you don't like it that's okay.
I understand. I'm not going to lose
sleep.
Go and find a person that will appeal to
you. Don't idolize him. Don't idolize
anyone. May God destroy every form of
idolatry blasphemy. Learn and focus on
Jesus because Jesus is perfect and
spotless and can never disappoint you.
And those who finish the race, those who
are in heaven, they can't sin anymore.
Let them be your role models. Amen.
Right. Can Paul ever fail ever again?
Nope. Let him be your role role model.
Can Peter ever fail? No, you can't. Let
him be your role model. As long as
there's breath in your
body and you are living in this fallen
world, God forbid. May Jesus never hand
me over. There's always a chance you can
fall away from the faith or fall into
scandal. But if you die in union with
Christ and you finish race, you can't
sin anymore. So look to them as your
role models, not to me. Amen. That's
good, Sam. I love your heart, man. Yeah.
That's what I tell people, right? I say,
"Well, my kids listen." Well, who told
you to let your kids listen? I say,
"It's 18 and older." When you, you know,
when you when you do a YouTube stream,
they ask you, "What's the audience?" I
say, "18 and older." Mhm.
Because I know my content it's not for
kids. So what you do is you take the
information, you learn it, and then you
teach it to your
kids. Your kids don't need to listen to
me. Yeah. You take what I have to offer.
Then you present it to them. That's
good. Right. This is my advice. So yeah,
and and yeah, I know I have sinned in my
anger. I'd be a liar if I said I didn't
because I'm not perfect. But that
doesn't mean that I'm wrong in insulting
because there is biblical basis.
Especially when you tell people, hey,
here are the rules. Don't come here and
attack us, mock us, ridicule us, insult
us, slander us. Don't come here and mock
the Bible, insult Jesus. Don't come here
pontificating because I'm warning you,
you disrespect my rules. You're asking
me to disrespect you and they do it
anyway. So that means they want to be
disrespected. Yeah. If you don't mind,
could you show um some of the biblical
basis? I did sessions on this, brother.
Do you want me to go over it again? No,
hold on.
I will. I mean, do you guys want me to
go through the list again of where
prophets are insulting people in some of
the most graphic manners
imaginable? I mean, I can show you that.
I even wrote a post on it. Let me show
you the post, okay? Because I've done it
several times. I wrote a post in
response to Muslims of all people trying
to use me treating them the way they
deserve and see he's not being
Christlike. So guess what I did to the
bastards? I did I wrote a post and let
me give you the context here. Setting
the record straight here it is. It's all
right there. Now, at this time, I didn't
add all the biblical references because
in here, in here, I actually have a
section on when is it right and if it is
right to mock and insult people. There
it is. Now, I didn't give all the
verses. There's a lot more verses, but I
didn't give. So, here
is when then I say why I treat these way
I do. And this is now the biblical
basis. You see it? So instead of me
going through the biblical case, here it
is. Now there's a lot more. I just gave
some right there. Mhm. So there you have
the documentation. People don't like my
approach. Go somewhere
else. You don't need to be here. But you
don't know what I deal with, whom I'm
engaging, and the threat upon our lives.
If these people had their way, they
would shoot me, shoot you, behead me.
And you can see I'm afraid not.
You want me there? I'm with you. So
there's your biblical basis, brother.
All right. You just go. I already took
more time than I should if I because
there are people waiting. But there it
is, the biblical basis. And I've done
sessions on this as well. There are
others where God speaks very graphically
saying, "I'll take the of animals
and smear it on your faces." Malachi
2:3. where God says, "I will laugh at
you and mock you." Here, the Lord scoffs
at them. I will also laugh at your
calamity. I will mock you. But the Lord
laughs at the wicked. See, he makes a
mockery out of them. Let alone Elijah
who mocked the prophets of Bal and
saying, "Maybe he's in the bathroom.
Maybe he's out in the toilet relieving
himself. That's why he can't hear you."
Where God calls his own people stupid.
For every man is stupid, foolish. Even
the Lord says, "You
fools, you idiots." It's a language, but
I guess they're going to accuse Jesus
not being Christlike.
All right. So, I hope that helped you,
brother. It did. Thank you so much for
your time, Sam. God bless you, Jenna.
God bless you.
So, guys, there's the record. Go watch
it.